Okay.
As a cultural critic,
I watch a lot of movies and I'm always on the lookout for positive Hollywood
representations of masculinity.
I usually walk out of the theater disappointed,
but occasionally the stars will align and I'll find myself pleasantly surprised
and that's how I felt after seeing the fantastic beasts and where to find them.
Yeah.
Newts commander protagonist of this Harry Potter spinoff is an unconventional
male hero.
The kind of character typically relegated to Sidekiq status.
He performs a refreshing Lee atypical form of masculinity,
especially for the lead in a fantasy adventure story.
His is a quiet,
vulnerable,
yet confident form
manhood
newts character is largely defined by his extraordinary ability to connect with
magical creatures and by his relative inability to connect with other human
beings.
Newt is,
imagine a zoologist,
essentially,
he's an expert in the care of magical creatures is life.
Work is passion,
is studying,
nurturing,
and protecting these fantastic beasts.
Then writing textbooks in an effort to foster understanding and compassion where
their plight to the loss breeding pair and exists.
If I hadn't managed to rescue them,
that could've been the end of the Grat poons forever.
I should mention that this is not a doctor.
Get a little situation newts.
Bond with an affinity for animals is not supernatural in nature even though that
wouldn't be out of place in this universe.
Instead,
you simply pays attention to them and their needs when others don't.
He had a cause.
He needed somebody or this is also not an animal.
Good human bad story.
Even though he's painfully shy and socially awkward newts.
Empathetic worldview extends to people especially to those discriminated against
or marginalized as evidenced by his disgust at the way American wizards treat
non magical people.
It's just commanded to you know anything about the wizarding community in
America.
I do know a few things actually.
I know that you have rather backwards laws about relations with not magic people
that you're not made to befriend them.
You can't marry them,
which seems mother live said to me,
just get to marry him.
Okay?
He's strongly opposed to segregation,
discriminatory laws,
capital punishment and other violence committed in the name of justice newts.
Truly special gift is not his magic.
It's his empathy.
All right,
I'm coming.
Mum's,
yeah.
This type of quiet sensitive masculinity is so out of the ordinary for a leading
man that I wasn't terribly surprised to see a number of movie reviewers turned
off by his character.
The New York Post said that newt was not a very engaging lead.
MTV said he lacked depth,
soul and a coherent personality.
The village voice went so far as to say he seemed physically ill much of the
time.
Slate felt that he was a little boring.
Both slate and the new republic lamented that the character tamped down Eddie
Redmayne is charisma.
The new republic also expressed shock at his leading man status,
saying that he's so good hearted,
simple and nondescript,
that it's sort of crazy.
He's going to be the centerpiece of a five film franchise.
I was disappointed,
but as I said,
not surprised to see this kind of reaction.
We as movie going,
audiences have been conditioned to expect a certain type of masculine
performance from male characters in Scifi or fantasy films.
We expect leading men who are or learned to be autonomous,
brazen and physically strong,
or at least men who are witty,
boisterous,
and charismatic,
preferably all of the above.
It's practically required for male heroes.
The hide their vulnerabilities.
We've learned too easily forgive aggression and arrogance and men,
but to take exception at presentations of humility or sensitivity,
we're accustomed to seeing men who are quick to violence and slow to diplomacy.
Newt is a significant departure from this trend.
His version of manhood doesn't stem from physical strength or combat skills or
feats of daring do that or even from some preordained mystic destiny,
like so many other male heroes.
He's sincere,
nurturing,
emotional and sensitive,
but that's definitely the lab.
He must be particularly susceptible and critically that sensitivity is framed as
a strength rather than a weakness.
Stay still.
That's just not the sweating.
When men in our culture express this kind of vulnerability,
they're often labeled week because nurturing and sensitivity are things that are
stereotypically associated with women and with femininity and by framing these
attributes as positive and heroic aspects of a male adventure hero,
it goes a long way to challenging regressive gender expectations.
Now,
in order for us to understand just how revolutionary newts performance of
masculinity is,
it's useful to talk a little bit more about all the things he's not
isis and liked to.
Che Newt is a British wizard who attended Hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry,
but new is not Harry Potter.
He's a Hufflepuff.
Actually,
no,
I am.
I'm a proud of puff.
The house characterized by friendship,
hard work and humility.
Hufflepuffs are said to be more down to earth and less competitive than the
other three wizarding houses.
Harry Potter on the other hand,
was sorted into Gryffindor.
The house known for daring nerve chivalry and prone to a fair bit of showing
off.
As such,
Harry fits neatly into the Pantheon of traditional Hollywood heroes is,
is the archetypal hero's journey.
And we all know how these fantasy character arcs are supposed to unfold.
And unsuspecting young man has adventure thrust upon him and it turns out that
he's the only one in the entire universe who can save the world.
Oh,
it was clumsy or random was a blast.
And does he is transformed from shy,
nerdy guy into triumph and bad ass.
It's not uncommon for this evolution to involve fighting with some sort of
flaming Phallus.
By contrast,
newts commander is not the chosen one.
He doesn't have some faded cosmic burden that he alone must shoulder.
Some have compared newt with doctor who because,
well,
where it isshe bow tie and bigger on the inside.
But that's really where the similarities end.
New Does harbor a deep inner pain,
but his personal struggle,
it doesn't manifest as arrogance.
Oh,
he's not interested in showing off his power in grand gestures.
So all of time and space,
everything that ever happened or ever will.
Where do you want to stop?
Newt is a humble caregiver who's content with his personal goal,
which let's remember is writing textbooks,
albeit magical textbooks,
but still that's surprisingly unassuming for a fantasy adventure hero.
This means that unlike potter,
Newt doesn't possess superpowers magic,
nor is he plagued with self doubt about his abilities.
It's or his place in the magical world
sit down is just commander.
He's a grownup,
already confident in his wizarding skills.
I can poison you even if he remains uncomfortable around others
and I suspect that this point might be another reason why some critics who
weren't so fond of this new wizarding protagonist.
Can I help you,
sir?
I think there's an argument to be made that new exhibits the characteristics of
someone on the autism spectrum.
He's awkward in social settings.
He doesn't like being touched.
He feels intense empathy for others,
but has trouble connecting to people and making friends and careful viewers will
also notice his a version to direct eye contact.
The films narrative never confirms this hypothesis one way or the other.
Perhaps this is simply how Eddie Redmayne decided to play the character,
but whatever the case,
it's a testament to both the writing and the acting that newts,
social anxieties are not framed in the stereotypical ways we've come to expect
from Hollywood.
Characters like this tend to fall into a few specific archetypes.
There's the tormented genius and brilliant,
but in sufferable character who's intelligent to the point of instability for
mental illness,
which is often framed as the price he must pay for his extraordinary talent.
There's the mad scientist or whimsical or bumbling character who's weird.
Eccentricities are perhaps endearing to a degree.
I'm going to read your thoughts,
but are also played for comedy and then there's the Sherlock Holmes archetype.
A character possessing such a superhuman Iq.
You pass me a pen that it leads to callousness
and the inability or perhaps on willingness to feel sympathy for other people.
Shut up.
I'm just saying that you were thinking it's annoying.
Okay,
but newt isn't too lost in his own mind or his own eccentricities to care about
or empathize with other people.
In fact,
quite the opposite is sensitivity is where he excels
critically.
Fantastic beasts,
doesn't frame newts.
Social anxiety as an obstacle he must ultimately overcome in order to be a true
hero.
The narrative doesn't require him to toughen up or learn to be more outgoing.
Newt doesn't fundamentally have to change his way of being and the people who
become his friends are those who interact and engage with him on his terms.
Come on.
New does learn and grow over the course of this adventure,
but it's a subtle,
more interpersonal growth.
Everybody knows newt only kept me around because he learns to make friends and
he learns to trust them.
What did you keep me around?
Because I like it
cause yours my friend.
Oh
and establishing these deep human connections is the core of his character
development.
It's been,
hasn't it?
The ending of fantastic beasts is rather anticlimactic compared to most other
action fantasy movies and even compared to most other films in the Harry Potter,
Right
Universe
as expected,
there's a final showdown with a powerful and destructive magical force.
But even here,
newts actions are guided by his empathy.
I'm here to help you.
Great.
Not Hey to her rather than besting his foe in an epic,
magical duel nude approaches the conflict with an eye for deescalation.
Of course,
in the end,
the malevolent force is vanquished,
but it's not done by newts hand.
Even more surprising.
This triumph over evil isn't shown to be a cause for celebration.
It is instead framed as a melancholy event,
melancholy because our hero's failed to save the monster.
I feel like I might need to say that again in this movie.
If feeding the monster is framed as a tragedy because they couldn't save him a
fittingly unconventional conclusion to an unconventional Hollywood fantasy
production,
it remains to be seen if Warner brothers has the guts to keep newt as the
protagonist throughout all five films in the franchise for her park.
J K Rowling has said that new will remain the star,
at least for the next movie in the series,
but within Hollywood there's no doubt enormous pressure to shift the focus to a
character who performs a more traditional and expected type of man.
The studio has even hinted at demoting newts role,
and that would be a shame because we need more movies.
That center a gentle,
empathetic version of heroic masculinity.
If you'd like to see more videos related to media and manhood,
hop on over to my patrion page and help fund the pop culture detective agency.